you've fought to do your own stunts in
this movie of course they're saying well
we don't want you to the stunts the
insurance Tom Cruise likes to do his own
stunts and you said you wanted to do
your own stunts as well yeah I was very
adamant you know tom is very smart he
chosen actresses I was way more bravery
than common sense so I everyday you know
I was adamant that I would like you know
be able to do whatever he could do and I
was I was so clear that I wanted to run
on screen with him you know he's an
iconic runner so ever in the mornings we
would train together and I would time it
so just before I'd get on the treadmill
and I'd amp it up and I'd be in there
like yes there's a kind of running that
people do in movies and Tom Cruise I
practically invented it that no one runs
that way in real life no it looks so
cool in a movie in but you know they're
like you know and in real life I'm just
that's you know that's everyone they
have to train you how to do that yeah
yeah because that I think most people do
we have a clip here from the mummy and I
said this to you in the dressing room I
burst in what's that you're very tall I
know no one knows that I'm tall no one
knows that you're told no they hear
about it but then I came in and you were
like you're very tall and I saw a real
attraction in your eyes and then other
people what's that what's that I was
blown away yes yeah yes
I'm an idiot but yeah you have a I told
I I came to your dressing room and you I
told you you have a clip for this movie
that does not disappoint I've had so
many actors come out here and they they
say take a look at my clip and and this
is a really great action clip do we need
to know anything you think it needs any
setup at all you Tom Cruise a plane in
France zero-g we did it 64 times and
yeah we were weightless for 30 seconds
each time and we filmed this amazing
sequence so it was a stunt that Tom had
never done before right so she's running
out of stunts he's never done before yes
let's let's take a look at this clip
from the mummy
passive
you can do this you can do this
okay that's a quick
you